we've defined the notion of a projection
onto a subspace but i haven't shown you
yet that it's definitely a linear
transformation nor have i shown you that
if you know a basis for its subspace how
do you actually find the projection onto
it so let's see if we can if we can make
any progress on that here so let's say i
have some subspace let's say v
is a subspace
subspace
of rn
and let's say i've got some basis
vectors for v so let's say these are my
basis vectors basis vector 1
2 and i have k of them i don't know what
v's dimension is but let's say it's k
it's got k basis vectors
so is a basis
is a basis for
for v and that means that any vector
not not v that's not v vector that's v
subspace now that means that means that
any vector
any vector let me call some vector i
don't know let's say any vector a
that is a member of my subspace can be
represented
that means that a can be represented as
a linear combination of these guys
so i'll make my linear combination let's
say it is i know y 1 times b 1
plus y 2 times b 2
all the way to plus
y k
times b k
that's what the definition of a basis is
the span of these guys is your subspace
v so any member v can be represented as
a linear combination of my basis vectors
now if i were to construct
a matrix
a matrix let's make it an n
by k matrix
whose columns are essentially the basis
vectors of my subspace so a looks like
this the first column is my first basis
vector my second column is my second
basis vector and i go all the way in my
k column and i have k columns is going
to be my k basis vector
if i'm going to have my kth basis vector
let me make the closing bracket the same
color as my opening bracket
just like that it's going to have n rows
because each of these basis vectors are
members of rn remember v is a subspace
of rn so each of these guys are going to
have
n terms so this matrix is going to have
n rows
now saying that any member of the
subspace v can be represented as a
linear combination of these basis
vectors is equivalent to saying that any
any member that a that any
member a of our subspace v can be
represented
can be represented as
the product of our matrix a
our matrix a
times some vector
some vector y
where
somebody was equal to a
for
sum
y that is a member of
r k
now why is this statement that statement
equivalent well you can imagine if you
were to just multiply this times some
vector y in rk
so it's y1 y2
all the way down to yk this is going to
be equal to
y1 times v1 plus y2 times b2
all the way to plus
y k
times b
k which is the same thing as this if you
you can always pick the right linear
combination you can always pick the
right member of y k so that you get the
right linear combination of your basis
vectors to get any member of your
subspace v so any member of my subspace
right there can be represented as the
product of the matrix a with sum
with some vector in
rk and we don't know much about this
vector right here in rk now
the projection let's say that x is some
let's say that x is just some arbitrary
member of rn
the projection
of x
onto our subspace v
that is by definition it is going to be
a member of your subspace
or another way of saying it is that this
guy the projection
the projection onto v
of x is going to be equal to my matrix a
is going to be equal to i'll do it in
blue is going to be equal to a times
some vector y
for
some
vector
y
in rk if we knew what that vector y was
if we could if we could always find it
then we wouldn't have we would have a
formula so to speak for figuring out the
projection of x onto v but we don't have
that yet all i've said is any any member
of v can be represented as a product of
our matrix a which has
these which has the basis for v is
columns and some member of rk that just
comes out of the fact that these guys
span v that any member of v is a linear
combination of that those guys we know
that the projection of x onto v is a
member of our subspace v it has to be
inside of v
so it can also be represented this way
now what was our definition of our
projection
our definition of our projection we say
well let me write it this way we know
that x
we know that x
can be represented
as the sum of the projection
the projection onto v of x plus
some member of v complement or maybe i
could even write plus the projection
the projection of
the projection onto the orthogonal
complement of v
onto
the projection of x onto the orthogonal
complement of v you could write it this
way i could have also written this as w
where w is a member of v complement
actually let me write it that way that
might make it simpler i don't want to
get right too many projections here plus
w
where
is
a unique member a unique
remember
of
the orthogonal complement of v or you
could say it this way if you subtract
the projection of of x onto v from both
sides you get
x
minus the projection
of x onto v
is equal to w
is equal to w or another way to say it
is that this guy right here is going to
be a member of the orthogonal complement
of v right because this is the same
thing as w now what's the orthogonal
complement of v
if we go back to this matrix here i have
these basis vectors
right here as the columns so the column
space
the column space
of a
is going to be equal to v right the
column space of a is just the span of
these basis vectors and by definition
that is going to be equal to my subspace
v
now what is the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement of v is going
to be the orthogonal complement of my
column space
is going to be the orthogonal complement
of my column space and what's the
orthogonal complement of a column space
that's equal to the null space
of a transpose or you could also call
that the left null space of a but that
we've seen that many many videos ago
so we could say that x minus the
projection of x onto v is a member of
let me write it this way
x
minus the projection
onto v of x
is a member
of the orthogonal complement of my
column space of my matrix which is equal
to the null space of a transpose
of a transpose that's the orthogonal
complement of v this is the same thing
as the orthogonal complement of v
but what does this mean
what does this mean right here this
means that if i take a transpose
and i multiply it times this vector
because it's a member of a transposes
null space
so if i multiply it times that vector
right there
so projection of x onto v
that i'm going to get 0 i'm going to get
the zero vector that's the definition of
a null space so let's write this out a
little bit more let's see if we can
algebraically manipulate it a bit so if
we distribute this matrix vector product
we get a
transpose times the vector x minus
a transpose
times the projection
projection
actually let me write this this way
instead of keep writing the projection
onto v of x what did we say earlier in
this video we said that the projection
of v onto x can be represented as the
matrix product of the matrix a
times some vector y in rk that's where
we started off the video so let me write
it that way because that's going to
simplify our work a little bit so
instead of so i'm going to distribute
the a transpose a transpose times x and
then a transpose minus a transpose times
this thing this thing i can write as a
times
some vector
y and that was just from just this is
just a byproduct of the notion that the
projection is a member of our subspace
because it's a member of our subspace
it's going to be some linear combination
of the column vectors of a
we saw that up here so it can be
represented in this way so it can be
represented this way so instead of
projection onto v of x i can just write
a
y
this thing and this thing are equivalent
because this thing is a member of v and
then all of that is going to be equal to
zero
and then if we add this to both sides of
this equation we get that a transpose
x
is equal to
a
transpose
of y
or now this is interesting now remember
what we where we started off here we
said that the projection
the projection onto v of x
is equal to a y
for sum
for some y and for some y that is a
member of our k if we knew what that y
was if we could always solve for that y
then we then the projection of x would
be well defined and we could always just
figure it out
now can we solve for y here well we'll
be able to solve for y
if we can take the inverse of that
matrix if this matrix is always
invertible then we're always going to be
able to solve for y here because we can
just take the inverse of this matrix and
multiply it times the left side of both
sides of this equation
now if you remember three videos ago
three videos ago i think it was three
videos ago i showed you that if i have a
matrix a
a whose
whose columns
are linearly independent
then a transpose a
is always
always
invertible
the whole reason why i did that video is
for this moment right here
now
what about our matrix a
well our matrix a has column vectors
that form the basis for a subspace by
definition basis vectors are linearly
independent so our matrix a has columns
that are linearly independent and if you
watch that video and if you believe what
i told you then you know that a
transpose a in our case is going to be
invertible it has to be invertible so
let's take the inverse of it and
multiply it times both sides so if we
take a transpose a
inverse we know that this exists because
a has linearly independent columns and
multiply it times this side right here a
transpose
x
and then on this side we get
we're going to do the same thing a
transpose a
inverse
times this thing right here
a transpose a
y
these two things when you multiply when
you multiply the inverse of a matrix
times a matrix you're just going to get
the identity matrix so that's just going
to be equal to the identity matrix and
the identity matrix times y is just
going to be y so we get and this is a
vector so if i flip them around i get
that y
is equal to
this expression right here
a transpose a
inverse which will always exist
times a transpose times x
now we said that the projection of x
onto v is going to be equal to a times y
for some y well we just solved for the y
using our definition of our projection
we just were able to solve for y so now
we can we can define our projection of x
onto v as a matrix vector as a matrix
vector product so we can write
the projection
onto v
of our vector x
is equal to
a
is equal to a
times y and y is just equal to that
thing right there
y is equal to that thing right there so
a times
a transpose
a inverse which always exists because a
has linearly independent columns times a
transpose times x and this thing right
here this long convoluted thing that's
just some matrix
some matrix
which always exists for any subspace
that has some basis so we've just been
able to express the projection of x onto
a subspace as a matrix vector product
so this says so anything that can be any
matrix vector product transformation is
a linear transformation
is a linear transformation and not only
did we show that it's a linear
transformation we showed that look if
you can give me the basis if you can
give me the basis for v i'm going to
throw that basis into some i'm going to
make the those column vectors equal to
the column of some matrix a and then if
i take matrix a if i take its transpose
if i take a transpose times a and invert
it and if i multiply them all out in
this way i'm going to get the
transformation matrix for the projection
now this might seem really complicated
and it is hard to do by hand for many
many projections but this is super
useful if you're going to do some
three-dimensional graphical programming
if you have
if you have you know let's say you have
something in you know you have these
cube let's say you have some you know
three dimensional object
let's say you have some three
dimensional object
and you want to know what it looks like
from the point of view of some observer
so let's say you have some observer some
observer's
point of view is essentially going to be
some subspace right you want to see what
the projection of this cube onto the
subspace how would it look to the person
who's essentially onto this flat screen
right there how would that cube look
from this point of view
well if you know the basis for this
subspace you can just apply
this transformation you can you know
make a matrix with whose columns are
these basis vectors for this observer's
point of view and then you can apply
this to every vector in this cube in r3
and you will know exactly how this cube
should look from this person's point of
view so this is actually a super useful
result